[Applause]
here he comes the other way there's your
first James Jam of his career man I
still remember your rookie year that
first game in Sacramento got the
Breakaway done
to the side crowd was going crazy when
he was 18.
congratulations on a terrific terrific
career as you keep going watch this one
wow what a start
[Applause]
he has Arroyo in front got battles on a
bounce to James my favorite play
probably just comes down to the one in
Milwaukee where D Wade throws the pass
and then he's kind of has arms
outstretched and LeBron's flying through
there and dunking it just because of how
iconic that photo was probably makes my
favorite play
holy smokes
carry them down to James with a new shot
clock
everybody even myself included thought
that ball was going to Kyle Korver right
there for easy three
love long Outlet pass to LeBron he makes
the catch he steps behind the line turn
around three on the way oh
LeBron James backed it in with three
tenths of a second remaining he's tied
this game oh my word you have to be
kidding me
[Applause]
the guy he said something ah and then he
gets into a little two-step boom boom
like y'all like Jaw crowd's going crazy
that right there is a 10 out of 10.
[Music]
[Applause]
no way
there's an earthquake in Cleveland Ohio
and we talked about extensions that
exception
there's three seconds left on the clock
you're in the huddle with your teammates
what are you telling them give me the
ball three seconds left Cleveland
triggers it James two seconds one second
for the win
[Applause]
that's a winner in Cleveland
the only reason I think this is my
favorite play is because I I called it
out before it happened I remember
watching that game I said bro I'm about
to dunk on somebody
[Applause]
and as soon as I said it he in and out
and done and I just got hyped like
I told you I know Brian and he came down
the lane and kg was about to jump and he
dumped it that's special to me because I
was like I remember watching it at that
age when I was watching was a player
always stood out to me now that day I
was working with Doug Collins and when
LeBron went up Doug took his arm and
thrusted against my chest and both of
our chairs went backwards and we were in
the lamps of the people in back of his
watching in Cleveland that night
[Applause]
[Music]
my goodness
[Applause]
and just bullets in a powerful Tomahawk
slam check
LeBron James
foreign
[Applause]
I said you know what that's an accident
so I had to rewind this play one time
two times three times by the fourth time
I said okay he meant to do that that's
why he's King James
my favorite Brian cliff ever has to be
when he was a Cleveland and a donkey out
of James Johnson against Chicago
[Applause]
that was just like just a force and how
high he was that was probably the crazy
highlight and that's probably my
favorite one ever
[Applause]
no timeouts remaining for Cleveland now
and they've got the ball
[Applause]
throws up the floater
good night Cleveland that is for you
I mean I live for those moments to be
able to go out and come through for my
team you know it's a great feeling to be
able to do that and my guys
hey trust me
[Applause]
the greatest shot block of all time that
I've seen was probably LeBron in the NBA
finals
[Applause]
that was that was an amazing Vlog came
out of nowhere got it at the rim Thiago
was just about to put it through through
the cylinder and he got it at the room
you can see Ron's arm like almost bent
back and push it out so that was
exciting and the strength of LeBron
James to stop this and throw it back
one second to play gets it to LeBron for
three for the win yeah
what do I remember most I've had to
watch it Time After Time After Time for
the last 13 years around playoff time if
I had had my defender on the ball
tracking LeBron James we might have been
able to take that shot away that's what
MVPs do those kind of shots
favorite play Byron he got so many plays
man it's hard to just choose one the
reverse dunk he did with the Lakers
that was just like Kobe's it's probably
my favorite play
[Applause]
something
crazy LJ 20 years with the highlights
you've given us been unbelievable
unfortunately I've been part of one of
them highlighters I'm reminded of it all
the time when I'm walking around how did
it feel when LeBron jumped over you in
Miami oh he does it again and he goes
right over Lucas I didn't even see that
on the play originally it was like a
stepladder
that was a hell of a play my dad keep
going salute
[Applause]
LeBron was in Cleveland and they was
playing in Detroit in the playoffs you
know that game like he went crazy he
actually had to get an IV I think after
that game but I was there I drove down
to Detroit you know because it was just
so crazy to see all the shots that he
was making James has the fire and
Cavaliers Come Away with an improbable
Victory 48 points probably one of the
games I never forget
my favorite LeBron play I always say the
alley-oop in Boston Jason Terry
my favorite LeBron player would have to
be the live he called on Jason Terry
I hate to do it to Jet but the the log
against Boston dunking on Jason but
that's that's probably my favorite that
was crazy
[Applause]
Jason Terry and that stared him down
[Applause]
probably the favorite one is the block
against Golden State I think that was a
pretty amazing play like a dollar to
Curry back there you go down
by James LeBron James with the rejection
his third block of the game LeBron's
Block in the finals it was amazing you
know the way he got back in transitioned
and then to make a play like that on the
stage it's incredible I thought I'd have
to say that block in the finals versus
Golden State uh on Iguodala you know him
protecting both sides of the room I'm
not the he's the only person in the road
that can make that play and you know
that's what makes him you know Second To
None you know arguably the greatest
player to ever play the game
oh
[Music]
my God
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
back
[Music]